hey Bill this is Amy from Minnesota I
was wondering if when I was five years
old I did this science experiment where
we stuck a stick in salt water and it
made a crystal I was wondering if there
was in terms of desalinating water for
human consumption if there's a chemical
compound that could work as a catalyst
for some sort of reaction and if you
could do this on a massive scale Amy
that is a fabulous question
desalinization of water could be the key
to the future for so many of us us
humans now I am fascinated with this
question and so you use the word
catalyst this would be a chemical that
would enable another chemical reaction
within general doesn't affect the
catalyst so you could reuse the catalyst
right now as far as I know there is no
such thing but two aspects of this that
are really important right now the first
one is not real and I cannot help but
hearken to to a book by Kurt Vonnegut in
which he creates the characters create
something called ice 9 they get water
molecules to rearrange themselves and
the chemist who does this is fascinated
with the way cannonballs are stacked on
in statues or in memorials to people who
fought wars with cannons
that's fictional but it is kind of a
cool idea I won't tell you what happens
at the end of the book it's big fun the
real thing that's going on right now is
people are able to take the salt out of
salt water by forcing the water
backwards through a very fine filter
which generally is called a membrane and
right now we call it and osmosis and it
was an old Greek word that means kind of
happens on its own and so the classic
example is to take an egg take the shell
off with vinegar and then put the the
membrane contained egg in salt water
and the water will go into the egg and
the egg will swell if it's in salt water
if you put that same type of a naked egg
and distilled water the egg embryo is
slightly salty so it'll dassault the
water will work its way out in that egg
will shrink but anyway people have found
ways to make synthetic membranes with
things like Teflon and polyester and so
on and you can pump force the water
saltwater backwards through the membrane
and leave the salt behind and this is
done all the time it's done in Australia
at several industrial scale citywide
installation San Diego Carlsbad
California has won and cruise ships and
I guess the US Navy exploit this
technology all the time but Aimee
people are trying this new material
which has come to be called graphene and
it's just like graphite it's just like
the the thing that makes coal black or
pencil-lead gray except this material
now is one molecular layer thick and it
has these amazing properties it's
fantastically strong when stretched
longitudinally or in the same direction
and the plane of the graphene is crazy
strong and so people believe that the
slip length as it's called of the salt
water is longer than the thickness of
this one molecule or one atom thick
graphene so there's hardly any pressure
needed to get the water to flow through
the graphene leaving the salt behind and
having fresh water coming on the other
side now the key to any of these
processes is you have to filter the
water first to take out regular old
particulates regular old dust and sand
oh I exaggerated trash you got to take
that out before you run it through your
reverse osmosis membrane or this new
being experimented with graphene but you
we're living at a time where this
breakthrough may be made on an
industrial scale and if we can do that
Amy it would change the world we could
have all the clean water we wanted for
everybody over the world and we would
power the pumps with solar power barrel
photovoltaics solar cells and when the
sun's not shining you don't pump the
water so you pump the water when the sun
shining and you fill up reservoirs all
over the world and so humankind could if
we if this stuff works out could have
access to clean water for the billions
of us that need it it's an exciting time
Amy go get them become a chemical
engineer or material scientist and solve
this problem